Kevin McCarthy house Republican leader
has just come out and finally after
weeks of speculation he has said they
are going to open an impeachment inquiry
into Joe Biden that's why today
I am directing our house committee to
open a formal impeachment inquiry into
President Joe Biden
this logical Next Step will give our
committees the full power to gather all
the facts
and answers for the American public
it's exactly what we want to know
the answers I believe the president
would want to answer these questions and
allegations as well all true this is a
smart thing to do it will keep Biden a
little bit on his heels hopefully get us
a little bit more information about
Biden keep the story of Biden's
corruption in the news if nothing else
the best argument against Biden's
impeachment of course is Kamala Harris
she has got nothing Joe Biden seems like
he is a Rhodes scholar compared to
Kamala